So just everything is going wrong for Donald
Trump.
I think you're going to like this one.
We talked yesterday about the great developments
in terms of the coronavirus vaccine.
The vaccine being developed by Pfizer was
announced yesterday to have a 90 percent effectiveness
in a large clinical trial, has not yet been
peer reviewed, but it looks very good.
Donald Trump immediately tried to attach his
name to it immediately, tweeting in all caps,
stock market up, big vaccine coming soon report
90 percent effective.
Such great news.
Vice President Mike Pence also weighed in
and he just straight up tried to take credit
for it.
He tweeted, huge news.
Thanks to the public private partnership forged
by Trump, Pfizer announced its coronavirus
vaccine trial is effective, preventing infection
in 90 percent of its volunteers.
This is all made up.
And in fact, it's such nonsense that Pfizer's
head of vaccine research immediately clarified.
We took no money from Trump's so called operation
warp speed.
Katherine Janssen, head of vaccine research
at Pfizer, told The New York Times, We have
never taken any money from the U.S. government.
She also told The New York Times that Pfizer
was never part of Operation Warp Speed.
It's actually hilarious that Trump and Pence
are trying to crowbar their way into this.
And as reported by Bloomberg, quote, Among
the front runners, theirs is the only vaccine
project that did not take funding from the
White House led Operation Warp Speed program.
To bolster research, development or manufacturing,
you, like almost start to feel just the tiniest
bit sorry for these people, but we actually
don't because they keep insisting they won.
But but Biden did fraud and all this different
stuff.
No, that's not true.
OK, but now they say we got we got the vaccine
done because we gave Pfizer money.
Well, no, Pfizer didn't take any money from
you.
OK, well, something something.
And they get nothing.
There's actually even more hilarity to this,
which is that this is really a German vaccine.
Work on this vaccine started in Germany in
January because the CEO of Biogen Tech, which
is the partner company with Pfizer that developed
the vaccine, the CEO of Biogen Tech, read
about the virus in the Lancet and realized
this is going to be huge.
So they immediately started working on the
vaccine.
Meanwhile, Trump in January was saying, oh,
we've got this completely under control.
It's one person from China.
It's going to be fine.
Trump saying, and was it March 15 cases or
maybe even April 15 cases will soon be zero.
That's why this vaccine is now almost ready,
because in Germany, when Trump was doing nothing,
they started working on it.
Donald Trump and Mike Pence are trying to
take credit for a vaccine, but it was actually
a vaccine developed in Germany by a German
company founded by Turkish immigrants produced
in the US by a company that took no money
from Donald Trump's operation.
Warp speed.
That's the truth.
Don't let the door hit you on the way out.
Guys will have continued coverage of the vaccine.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter where
you can find me at department
The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.